Denise is bored.
It is winter vacation, and she is out of ideas of things to do.
"I wish it would snow," she says.
While Denise waits for snow, she does puzzles.
She plays games.
She reads books.
One book she reads gives her a huge idea.
She calls three neighborhood friends and says,
"Come to my house today at two o'clock!"
Denise lays a blanket on the floor for a stage.
She gets a wooden spoon for a microphone.
She gets markers and a big pad of paper.
She also gets her CD player.
Then she makes her game.
She gets ten cards and writes a direction on each one.
DING-DONG.
Denise puts the cards in a box just as her friends arrive.
"Ready to play Talent Show?" squeals Denise.
Marcus pulls the first card from the box.
"Dance to a song," he reads.
The friends laugh and cheer as Marcus dances.
All afternoon the friends play the game.
They dance, sing, draw pictures, and tell stories.
The friends are having so much fun.
They don't see that it's snowing.